hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and this is a follow-up video
to a video i did earlier in the week on
automating
the order flows sequencing tool in
markers and you know many people believe
that automated trading is good because
it can help take the emotion out of
trading
you know because when people are trading
manually and by manually i mean you know
just you know entering using your mouse
as opposed to having a computer do it
for you
they're often influenced by their
emotions and make decisions that are not
based on logic right they deviate from
their trading plan however you know when
you automate your trading system then
it's basically designed to trade based
on a preset rules and criteria
which means that the emotions are no
longer a factor so
let's
jump into it and you know the other day
i
laid out the steps to
um
what do you want to call it uh automate
the order flows sequencing tool in
markers
and again it's very easy to do i'll just
sort of take you through the steps
really quick
again this is ultra bonds this is a one
minute chart
and all you got to do is you add the
indicator
okay make sure it shows up down there
change it to
the settings that you want to use and
then you're going to add
markers plus
and two
copies of markers copy one for the buy
one for the cell and you just sort of go
in here and make the changes
um this is a day
you know this video is really meant for
people that
are thinking of getting the sequencing
tool
or
getting
markers
i don't sell markers it's from another
vendor it's from pablo at the indicator
store and it's it's a
great tool for automating your trade
entry
which is you know i i use it to
um
mainly as a trade entry tool i mean you
can use it as a full blown um entry and
exit take profit but you know i trade
the order flow so i like to
you know read what's happening in the
market right because you know that's the
whole point of reading order flow is
understanding what's happening in the
market because you know there's times
where you know when you
set something automatic right a trading
system to be automatic you really have
to be
on point with your
stop level
and you know sometimes your take profit
is
too tight okay sometimes you want to
have it
you know a bit wider take advantage of
the trade
you know because you know if you have a
take profit that's just
um you know say eight ticks or something
but the trade runs 20 ticks and you only
you you take out at eight ticks right
instead of catching you know double that
so
while automated trading does have its
advantages you know it does also have
some limitations but let me just get
this set up here really quick
and then
i'll talk some more about it but let me
just go through the setup process again
you see
it's
really very simple to set up
it doesn't take i'm just setting it up
from scratch i do have it loaded but i
want people to sort of get used to it
and see
how easy it is to actually set up
the tool
okay
this is the cell signal okay
in the other video i went through the
all the whole entire steps involved
but yeah again it's really simple in the
description below you'll have
all the
instructions for how to set it up
okay we should be good to go one last
thing to do
add the chart trader
okay in the the last video that i did
the other day
i use my regular ultra bond stop level
which is
you'll see here is five and seven okay
and
again
whenever you enter a trade you should
always
have the computer set up i mean now all
trading platforms pretty much have it
but
have your stop automatically as soon as
you get longer get short have your stop
to get out you know so you don't have
unlimited risk and throwing to take
profits okay and five and seven you know
some people said well that's very um you
know very tight
you know some people like to say you
know
these gurus out there people that have
just been training for
uh
since the
covet hit basically the last year and a
half you know
these are the ones that you see posting
oh yeah i had a great day you know you
should always have a 10 to 1 risk reward
ratio you know unfortunately
markets don't always go
ten to one right so you gotta you
understand the market you're trading me
i know what type of trader i am right
i'm a short-term intra-day trader um
more on us closer to a scalper than a
day trader and so i have
a lot of trades that i'm taking during
the course of the day and you know you
don't have to use five and seven right
you could use five and ten um you know
you could use five and
nine or you could use four or nine um
it's up to you you know understand you
do your research on the market to find
out
you know based on your trading strategy
sort of you know what kind of runs you
get um
you know how much risk are you willing
to take
and you know i'll just keep this at five
and nine actually let me see here i'll
what i'll do is i'll create a new one
here i'll go here new custom
okay
use five and nine that's almost uh
was that two to one
you know five and ten would be two to
one but
you know i like to adjust my take
profits because there's times where it
goes within one tick if you take profit
and then reverses and goes to your stop
and you know by watching the market by
watching the order flow um
if it comes if i see it gets within one
tick of my take profit and starts
reversing
i may choose to get out earlier rather
than get stopped out or i may move my
stop to break even so rather than taking
a five tick stop i'm able to
you know basically scratch the trade so
i'll save this as
call it uh ultrabond
ub
five by nine so five tick
stop nine tick take profit so just under
two to one
and i'll click uh
okay to save it
so go through some of these last minute
checks make sure
what counts we got here do i have the
playback mode not yet
all right here's my ninjatrader
okay
pull back playback connection okay
i wasn't connected there to playback so
what you got to do is make sure the
account here is the same here again i'm
shooting this it's um tuesday
morning
it's about 9 30 9 45. so i downloaded
the ultra bonds since you know since
sunday night 3 open it is now um again
wednesday morning about 9 30 ish
so i'm just waiting for the data to load
but make sure the ultrabond new stop
take profit level is set in right so
ultrabond five by
nine okay
all right so it's good to go here so let
me just uh
i'll just pause it for a second while
here it is we've come back up all right
so
so you can see it's starting on on
saturday
but uh let me just speed it up
it's gonna take a while to start running
okay so while it's catching up here
um
yeah i'll just talk about you know so
some of the pluses and the pros and cons
of automating trading is
the pros would be it's going to increase
your accuracy of trade execution right
because it's automating that process of
entering trades for you right so there's
less room for human error you're not
sitting around hemming and hawing uh do
i take this trade do i not take this
trade the computer doesn't care it just
it has its set rules
they're met boom it gets you into the
trade you know sometimes people get
um what do you want to call it
confused you know they they have their
way of trading their setup is there
to buy you know e-minis but they see
nasdaq is ticking down and uh you know
maybe i should wait a while
and e-mini's the trade
they don't take the trade the trade
worked you know so
um
it sort of removes that that bit of
hesitation
from your trading
so it's going to help you improve your
speed of execution and in a fast moving
market
manual trading you know point and click
using your mouse can be slow and
cumbersome you know sometimes you're
like especially if you've got multiple
screens right you're running around
trying to find where's my mouse at right
it's on some other screen or something
and by the time you click to trade the
market's already moving so you know by
automating
the process it helps you to execute your
trades
quickly and efficiently which is you
know
what you want to do right you want to be
efficient in your executions
and
you know a lot of people
don't understand that right and you know
the whole concept of execution
alpha um comes into play because you
know imagine you're taking
a lot of trades over
you know a period of time
imagine you could just improve your
execution right of
getting into a trade
by
a tick half a tick but you know you're
doing hundreds of trades
that half of a tick
you know say you're trading e-minis
right it's
you know 12 and a half bucks a tick
if you're
saving a half a tick that's you know
what six and a quarter but you do it
over how many hundreds of trades six and
a quarters uh adds up over time right so
you're six and a quarter over i don't
know a hundred trades is already six
hundred bucks
all right you're you're coming out ahead
okay we're coming up on the open okay
i'm just running the replay from
it started on you know my data went back
to the 26th
so the 27th but anyway here we are
okay so it's starting up
all right so again i have a
stop level of five ticks take profit of
nine ticks okay so
um
while there's the benefit the biggest
benefit to me is the execution part
in execution um for my trading strategy
there's drawbacks that you have to
consider as well right and
one of the main risks is sometimes you
know this sort of goes contrary is
you're going to end up trading more
frequently because
you are removing that
human factor so it doesn't care you know
whether
s ps are
going up and nasdaq is going down
it just takes the trade and i know some
people they won't take a
trade in the s ps if nasdaq is
going in the opposite direction
and if you're manually trading know you
might fall into that so you know if
you're taking every single trade that
comes through
then obviously your transaction costs
are going to go up because you're going
to be taking more trades and you have
obviously a potential for more losses if
the market is not performing as expected
and
you know that sort of leads into the
second part is
when you automate your trading
it loses sight of the overall market
picture what the market is doing and
why that's important is because you know
if the
if the market is going sideways
okay
that's not good trade location
right if you're in the middle of a value
that's forming right the market's just
sort of rotating around value you know
any trading strategy is not going to be
effective
right it doesn't matter you can have the
best
trading system in the world but if
you're in stuck dab in the middle of
the value area right or in the middle of
a consolidation it's probably not going
to be very effective
right the moves that happen
may not be your normal moves to your
take profit they'll be smaller okay but
if you automate your trading you don't
understand the computer doesn't
understand
the trading environment that you're in
okay
so you know that's to me that's one of
the drawbacks right
you should know that
if you're looking at the chart
and say oh you know we've been in this
tight range for the last
two hours okay maybe some news event is
happening or maybe there's a fed meeting
and they're gonna announce something
later in the day then
you know you might not want to be active
in the market right you you'd turn off
your
you know call it your
automated trading method
but
you know on a normal market conditions
you'd let it run so understanding the
market conditions that you're in
okay
so
trading systems sometimes do fail
right you can become disconnected to the
internet right maybe you don't realize
that um
and you can you know leave an order out
there hanging or something that's
working yeah one side working you know
there's certain issues that you have to
deal with just as you know when you're
dealing with electronic trading there's
always little issues that you got to
deal with
just you know bear that in mind but
really i think the the big difference is
the execution part because for many
traders
i feel that's the difference between
success and failure
all right so here we're going off what
time is this so now it's
monday it's about noon
where we're running plus 12 50.
again this is using a this is on ultra
bonds a one minute chart using a
five tick take profit uh five tick stop
at nine tick take profit
what time is it here it's 2 30.
again you know in all honesty
bonds interest rates after two o'clock
you know even though the market's still
open until four and you see there's a
nice little move up here
for all intents and purposes let me just
pause this here because we're at 4 20.
basically the time between two and and
four o'clock
there is trading
the futures are open but really cash
dealers are done for the most part
trading so see on monday
okay it ended up fourteen hundred
dollars okay that's using a take profit
of five and nine again this is all
hypothetical i'm just running this in
the playback mode um so let's move on to
monday
okay
all right here so monday's starting this
will reset
now it does have an open position going
on from
around the close on monday into the
reopen monday night
so you see that's why there was that
entry here and it got out up here
so let's just see how this goes on on
tuesday because you know i made the
video that i posted up on monday night
of the monday activity um i just want to
follow it up with
tuesday's activity as well
and i think i got the data until about 9
30 on on wednesday
so i'll just run it so what time is it
so it's about midnight
we're running down 60 bucks
we have a drink of water here
okay so let me just pause this here for
a second now say you're manually trading
this
okay
obviously you got an entry here
it doesn't stop you out and then it
starts coming down again
right
this is where discretionary trading
comes in you can always add you get
another couple signals in here you just
add on to your position you don't have
to close it out because you know it's at
your um target
you can just add on to it right and
catching more of the move down
so it gives you you know again that
flexibility if you're trading sort of i
don't say automatic but you know
semi-automatic you know
using it for your trade entry
using it um
then just manage the trades manually so
for example right here we are we're in
an area of consolidation sideways right
if i had
my order flow chart up
you know i might not want to be taking
so many trades in here but nevertheless
if you're using
fully automate automated trading it's
taking the trade stopping you're not
taking the trade stopping you out taking
the trade stopping you out
right and
some people can't handle i think there
was probably what one two looks like
this was one two three four
four losers in a row you know some
people they can't stomach that for some
reason but you know in trading that's
what happens you sometimes get
strings of losers just as you get um
strings of winners right so right now
it's we're running at minus
750 right and some people they'd want to
vomit already
but
you know here's that minus
what is that it's 800
but if you
have faith in your system have faith in
your trading
you know you're willing to to write it
out because
you've done the analysis you've done the
testing that you know that ultimately
you'll come out ahead okay so look at
this it's
what time is it here so it's 9.50 it's
down basically a thousand dollars down
9016 at one point it was down a thousand
but there's a lot of little trades in
here and again if you are
trading manually
right rather than getting stopped out on
some of these losers
you're able to
scratch the trade right so that's why i
talk about when i say
you know manage the trade right again
i i use order flow to manage my trades i
use
tools to automate the entry okay because
you know sometimes you know if you're
watching multiple markets it does get
confusing sometimes
because you're like oh you know
something's happened in this market and
then you miss
you know a trade because you're
concentrating on a position
and you don't get into the other trade
that you should
okay so here so
okay it's gone from what it's at plus 31
right now so obviously there was some
runs up here um
you know
this one you know got long at uh 09
stopped out at 04. and then along here
at you know 16 out at 25 long again
but if you're trading this you know you
may
you see you know the market running you
know in the order flow you might move
your
take profit from 07 up to
right if you see a strong market
but again you know i mean it comes down
to
it basically just it comes down to you
and your trading style and whether you
can do it and i said you know when i
talk about automated trading i i use it
for trade entry
right i'm not the type to just sort of
run it walk away from the computer for
the entire day and and just sort of come
back and see
how did i do
but um i mean you could
but you know i like to
watch what's happening in the markets
okay so here so we ended up
tuesday
okay it's 403
stopping this
had a lot of trades
it's down 31
but um you know we'll look at the trade
recap the amount of trades taken
um a bit later but again you know
this is that
time where it's very illiquid
but you do get some nice moves at that
time but if you were again you know if
you're trading this
right and you see it screaming up you
have your you know you're long at 01
actually i think yeah you're long at 01
right here or is it right here
and it starts going up and you see some
very strong buying okay
maybe you back off from
you know to 15. again
it's it's hypothetical because you know
i'm just showing you this in replay but
when you're watching the order flow you
know you can do that or if you're in a
trade
for example
uh you know it was
you know you're here right you get long
at 25 right up here and you just see the
market just drifting sideways drifting
sideways it's trading 22 your stops at
20.
you think i just you know we're in a
sideways nothing's happening right just
cut it at 22. you just saved yourself
two ticks basically you know and i'm
sure there's some other trades in here
where if you're
you know managing the trade
um
you know here's a nice here's a trade
okay so you're
getting short here at 06 okay your stops
at 11
starts grading down trades down
all the way down to what is that 30.
so that's seven ticks
but
your take profit is just right here at
you know at 28. then you start seeing it
come back up again your stops up here at
11.
it starts coming back up up up up
okay remember you're short at 06.
and you just got this move within
two ticks of your take profit maybe you
drop your stop down to you to o6 or
maybe you come down to o4
right because obviously you got this big
bar down if it starts coming back up
above that it's probably going to keep
going up so maybe you drop it down to 04
so instead of taking that five tick loss
you actually got a two tick profit
okay so
you know that's
if you're just trading fully automatic
automatic um
the computer's not going to make those
decisions for you right that's where you
as a trader have to come in and
you know make those decisions right
that's why you trade is to make the
decisions
all right so let's see here so this is
wednesday the reopen here
again i'm shooting this video it's about
nine
so it's coming up on 10 o'clock but i
think my data is until about uh 9 30 so
we'll see how
okay so look at that all right it's
already down
500 bucks
not a good again this is what i'm
talking about right
you're short here at uh where is it at
but then it came all the way back up
here and stopped you out
okay you just use the software to get
you in to the trade you're short at 04.
you know it goes all the way down to 28.
all right your
take profit is probably here at 26 or
27. but it's just going sideways in here
so rather than waiting for i'll come all
the way back up here to 09 to stop you
out you start seeing it again you're
short here right at 04. you start seeing
it tick back up
you drop your stop from 09 down to at
least 0 4 to break even or maybe you
know double o all right you got all
spending all this time below double o
you know so instead of having a
five tick loser you got a four tick
winner but again you know that's
for you know for traders that understand
how to trade
again we all like to have i like to
think that we could have automate
everything and
not just trading but in in life
um you know sometimes
you know it's best to just manage it
yourself
because remember right there's nobody
putting a gun to your head saying oh you
got to take this trade and stay in it
till it stops you out so like you know
this is one now this is one right you're
getting short here at 26 target's at
17. okay that's fine i know some people
again they would just drop their stop
down to 20.
all right they're short at 26 you know
stop down to you know 20 21 move their
target from 17
you know down another five ticks to 12.
okay they're willing to protect their
profit by moving their stop
and you know try to take
more out of the move
something similar here right you could
have gotten more out of that move
what are we at here sometimes it's three
in the morning um
plus 187
running into a rough patch here we're
sort of going sideways at the low
okay so like here like this trade right
there long from 30
trades all the way up to o4
spending a lot of time before it stops
you out down here at 25.
again you could have moved your stop up
right so there's different ways to
manage it
stop
literally it's uh
stopped here at 9 20. and it's at break
even um
so far for this wednesday
but you know hopefully you could
understand you can start to see this
right here we look at these trades you
know if you're managing your trades
all right let's get this out of the way
here
okay so you know you're long from 14
with your your target at 23.
you know it only pulled back to 19 so
you're at plus five again you move your
stop up to break even maybe you back off
from 23 up to 28
right or
you know you got some stuff going on in
here if if you tried to move your
um
you're short from 21
you know covered it at 12.
it didn't come down to what 10. you know
so if you honestly if you moved your
take profit here probably wouldn't have
filled you but you could have just moved
it
back
right could have
moved it back up to 12
you know or maybe you know definitely
drop your stop down to 15. and maybe
that kept you out of this other trade
the short at 11.
see what else
you know you could have managed a bit
better
there's always trades that you could
look back on and see how can i have
managed this better
yeah again you're along from 30 and it
just goes up just sort of hangs around
up there just move your stop up you know
if it's spending a lot of time above
your entry and it hasn't quite hit your
take profit consider moving your stop up
you know somewhere in the money
these are the worst ones where it
fills you on the low of the move and
stops you out up there then makes the
move down
um
again you know you're short here at at
22 it's going down down down starts
coming back rather than getting stopped
out up here at 27.
you know maybe you drop your
stop down to you know your entry once
it's
firmly in the money and it starts coming
back you know maybe you get stopped out
at 22 or 23. so there's you know there's
a lot of different ways
that you can manage it right i mean
trading is all about managing your risk
right and the risk comes up when you're
in a trade
basically now
let's look at this
trade performance right so total net
profit for
monday tuesday wednesday so far
thirteen hundred dollars most of it came
on monday
right now
wednesday is kind of break even and then
tuesday was kind of break even
obviously a lot of trades 152.
so sharp ratio 2.36
but some of these trades honestly you
could have
written out for more
for example
this one
that move
um the day before during the european
session it's also
it was
you know
this nice move down i think you could
just add it on rather than get out and
get short again
oops
am i on
you know this trade here
all right you're short at 12 your
target's at 03
but you probably
could have gotten more i mean it's once
it's in your favor down in here i mean
you just drop your stop down to
you're short at 12 you drop your stop
down to 0708
you move your targets
at least from 03 down to
you know
another 5 ticks would be 28.
and you just sort of see it hanging
around here maybe you can come up and
you know seeing the sideways activity
you get out at double oh
but again you know i think i think
catching all this
further
move down to 172.00 i think that's a bit
optimistic and in reality um you got
this area where it just sort of goes
sideways comes off goes sideways comes
off rallies back up
um i think you need balls of steel to
ride that down if you're a short-term
trader that is
so
you know hopefully this sort of clears
up you know some of the questions you
have about automating your trading and
again you know these are the the
instructions for
automating the order flow sequencing
tool with uh markers
again there they'll be in the
description below
so again if you're interested in the
sequencing tool go to orderflows.com
sequencing slash index.html
and
i'll see you guys on the inside you know
probably uh
well thursday i can't but probably by
friday i'll post up another video just
show you the rest of the week
in ultra bonds rather than just show you
the one day that
you had a big winner
um but honestly if
the the
difference of
your stop and take profit level right i
mean if i was using
the
five and seven which i
used on the original video it actually
had
different results
so
you know expanding it out is there's
going to be a difference in your results
and that's what
the nice thing about automating your
systems are you can see
the differences and the reason why i did
this video with a different stop and
take profit is because people have asked
me um why are you using five and seven
why not you know two to one or something
higher so
i shot this one using five and nine you
know maybe on on friday i'll sort of
recap it with you know the different uh
what do you call it you know the
different stop levels and or stop levels
the same but then different take profits
so you can see
because
you know
there's just so many different ways to
to trade it and i don't want to put out
a video and people say well mike didn't
use this that's what i have to use no
you gotta you're a trader you gotta
decide what works for you
so thanks everybody for watching this
video and i'll see you guys later